when you're the Super Bowl MVP
twice against the greatest dynasty of
all time the New England Patriots Tom
Brady Bill Belichick and you join a list
that includes Terry Bradshaw Bart Starr
Tom Brady Joe Montana Eli Manning is the
only Super Bowl MVPs that kind of don't
really know what that term dropped the
mic is but I guess if there was one I
had a baby you know there really is no
yeah but after that I don't know what
the term dropped the mic is Payton it's
dropped the mic that's what you do you
drop the mic after two Super Bowl MVPs
two of the greatest throws in NFL
history the David Tyree helmet catch the
throw to Mario Manningham in Super Bowl
46 is one of the all-time threading of
the needle throws we've ever seen it was
incredible
I think was a better throw than the time
the Tyree was just what the hell am i
doing I'm throwing it up for grabs and I
got lucky that throw tomorrow Mario
Manningham was all skill he'd beat the
Patriots twice and and look big cat okay
Eli Manning's retiring after 16 seasons
there's gonna be a debate over whether
or not it gets in the Hall of Fame I
think those Super Bowls will get him
there I think the name Manning will get
in there I think having Peyton and
Archie actively politic publicly and
privately will get in there he's getting
there it's just a matter of when yeah
he's absolutely getting there and I
understand it's a matter of when but I
have a question for you Mike a fun
hypothetical debate that I want to throw
out there Eli Manning when it comes to
you know discussing his career he was
always a birder above average he was
never the the top three quarterback in
the league at any point he never had a
run you know people say the Kurt Warner
thing it's kind of like that no Kurt
Warner was the best quarterback in the
NFL for a stretch they're putting up i
popping numbers Eli never had that he
did have the two Super Bowls and more
importantly he had the two Super Bowls
against the greatest quarterback and the
greatest coach of all time and probably
the greatest dynasty run so my question
to you Mike is if he'll I'm Manning had
won two Super Bowls and he beat the
Baltimore Ravens
and I don't know throw it out there the
San Diego Chargers are we talking about
it the same way today and that's okay
because it is the Patriots but it's very
funny how that is what has elevated to
Eli and probably rightfully so because
he is that big of a piece of history
when you talk about Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick but what do we always say you
can't write the history of the NFL
without the guy so if you can't then he
should be in one of the biggest moments
in the history of the entire league
is there another moment moment in the
past 20 years that resonates more than
that escape from pressure and the ball
being thrown not long after a Sunday
Samuel had nineteen and OH in his hands
on the sidelines remember that I mean it
was done the Patriots were winning this
game and he does that and Tyree holds on
to that ball and I know Tyrese the other
part of it as well but you you it's
indelible you can't make that go away
ever so yes it does make a difference
they kept the Patriots from going to
nineteen and oh it does make a
difference it was a Patriots again four
years later look at where they would be
if they had seven or eight already and
they should have ate already
they shouldn't want both of those games
so that I think that's look what is the
Hall of Fame but for a museum of
mythology and does Eli Manning not
deserve a spot in that mythology when
you consider those moments you consider
their name and you consider and we know
how this works the voters will be
bombarded with lobbying from Peyton and
Archie Peyton and Archie public and
private the guy is getting in whether he
was 117 and 117 whether he was 110 and
150 it doesn't matter he's getting in
because he would've did in those two
spots and because of who he's gonna have
pushing and pushing and pushing for him
to get in know he's getting in there's
no question I think he deserves to get
it I just find an interesting Mike that
when you're talking about Eli Manning's
career it's almost like we're not
talking about Eli Manning's career we're
talking more about the Patriots dynasty
and how he plays in part of that you
know what I mean like his story is is is
linked forever with that with the Tom
Brady Bill Belichick thing instead of
the other way around
here's the other thing too this is a
team that won two Super Bowls four years
apart who from both of those teams is
getting in if not Eli Manning I mean
stray hands in but he wasn't there for
the second one stray hands there for
Super Bowl 42 and everything before
you've got a team that won two Super
Bowls in a four-year stretch usually you
see multiple guys from those teams get
in when you start to build I don't wanna
call it a dynasty but you've won to
within four years there's only one guy
who's a common thread from those teams
that's getting in the guy who was the
MVP in both games it's Eli Manning and
there's really nobody else yeah Tom
Coughlin should be getting in as well
maybe Brandon Jacobs because he
revolutionized you know brand Jacobs
walked so the Derek Henry could run
maybe that maybe he was ahead of his
time or why are you giving me that face
you don't like little fun no but but you
you undermine your point by saying
Brandon Jacobs you mentioned Tom
Coughlin though yeah I mean I mean Mike
Shanahan is not in should Tom Coughlin
be in before Mike Shanahan zin I don't
know well I mean if we want to go down
this road and this is gonna be a
ricochet shot but both guys should be in
before Bill cowers in I agree with you I
agree with you completely I think Mike
Holmgren should be in if Bill cowers in
yeah here's the reality here's here's
reality and we only got 30 seconds but
Bill Cowher has been on TV ever since he
stopped coaching Jimmy Johnson's been on
TV ever since he stopped coaching Mike
Shanahan isn't Mike Holmgren
isn't Tom Coughlin isn't and if you
don't think that's a real factor when
it's time to pick the Hall of Fame you
ignore the fact that it's human beings
who ultimately make these decisions
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports